j'appelais 2-2 pourtant plaindre je les
rattrape et entre sept et marseille
quel est le bon sens qu'il avait chiffré
mais chapeau de mireille canton clavreul
je les rattrape et entre certaines
marseille uk jolivent d'aller chiper ce
n'est pas le saisir mais pu suffire
c'est pas lui non plus qui l'on joue
plus c'est pas pour autant longtemps non
mais c'est le plus facile ou plus
magistrale de la panda et on a un moule
mistral il me l'a dit connaître aussi
dorénavant je ne me plais mambé cas des
moulins francs quand la gippe admirait
vieux os se trouve ça au se
retroussaient égouts fond des mers frais
et uk les enfants qui s'étaient remises
à la jupe à mireille où se trouve sa
hausse ce retour ça dit courant des
méfaits et que quelques jolies voix ses
vernissages c'est pas le zéphyr aurait
pu suffire c'est pas lui non plus là qui
l'on joue plus c'est pas pour autant
l'otan n'ont baissé le plus folles et
les plus magistrales de la panda et
alain hamou le mistral il me montra sa
jambe aussi reconnaissant je lui laisse
emporter mais depuis deux sont patents
où on s'embrassait mire l ue qu elle se
cabra qu'elle me rembarre à petit roeulx
lez sereine et uk de bon irna sans bras
chambas et mireille reste outtara
calmera mara le tir allait serait mieux
quel joli martin sombra c'est pas le
zéphyr on aurait pu suffire c'est pas
lui non plus là qui ne jouent plus
serait pas pour autant l'otan dans
baissier le fefan et le plus magistral
de la panda et un hammam où le mistral
il met parquet la gipsy de du montois y
avait qu une girouette en vienne a
maintenant droit
higuain avec mireille dans le fossé où
ces temps là c'est à l'ombre d'une
treille quel est le bon temps qui nous a
poussés et quand avec mireille dans le
fossé or c'est dans la tête à l'ombre
d'une très jolie quand vous a poussée
c'est pas le déficit film c'est pas lui
non plus à qui l'on joue plus c'est pas
pour autant l'otan n'ont baissé le plus
fun mais magistrale de la panda yoland à
bout le mistral il me couche assuré
lundi change aussitôt juni survol de
plus à mon petit paquebot la la la la
et voici maintenant le couple aidé à
dieu ainsi dénommée parce que georges
brassens l'a écrit à fontainebleau en
oui
que j'ai penché
le coeur à free g
des larmes sans
quelle jolie vont les assister c'est pas
le site inauka ru bercé par une nouvelle
à qui elles ont joué très bas bhoutan
l'otan mais c'est le plus connu de plus
magistrale de la panda yoland avoue le
mistral il balaya ma peine six ans les
six des huit ans notre
bébé